aber damals luca um meine lieben freunde
vor 12 wochen habe ich ein großes
gewinnspiel auf meinem instagram account
könnt ihr gerne alle forderungen da habe
ich auf den fall eine mega bundes
gewinnspiel veranstaltet im rahmen der
google play flecken kampagne mit
unterstützung von google play und zwar
konnte die dort ein riesiges harry
potter paket gewinnen konnte diesen mega
leisten um hier gewinnen wir schon mit
vendor logo drauf wie contest einen
zauberstab gewinnen die continental
gewinnen und sie konnte ich auch
verschiedene figuren gewinnt wie
beispielsweise professor dumbledore der
größte
wir sind auf jeden fall noch viele
weitere sachen drin wie beispielsweise
die bohnen von berti bots oder hier
beispielsweise auch noch so ein schal
noch extra und ob also sind auch dieses
coole sache mit drin und drei von euch
konnten diese sachen gewinnen und das
hier sind die drei gewinner die wir
ausgesucht haben also ich fand es auf
jeden fall megacool euren ministeriums
ausweis zu begutachten soll ein paar
schicken denn später kanada gekommen
die drei gewinner wurden auf jeden fall
schon kontaktiert und das paket ist auf
dem weg zu euch also dann kann euch
keiner fürs mitmachen und ich würde
sagen auch noch mal danke schön
eingebettet das heißt ich wünsche mir
dass wir das der veranstaltung durften
und jetzt gehen wir doch mal raus und
spielen selbst ein wenig das neue harry
potter rezession als diese woche ja und
ich weiß wie sehr sich aus befand auch
aus in der teams und den schulen
wieder sind jetzt draußen angekommen
bevor wir mit dem spiel anfangen möchte
euch das spiel natürlich erst mal ganz
kurz erklären und zwar ist es quasi wie
pokémon go nur dass man nicht die hände
im gegensatz zu pokémon wo man ja viel
mehr kämpfen muss gegen die anderen
pokémon geht es bei dem harry potter
spiel darum dass man harry potter
charaktere mit hilfe des nach mainz von
zaubersprüchen von ihren dunklen mächten
befreit
hört sich kompliziert an ist aber
relativ easy eigentlich friedensstifter
solche charaktere wie beispielsweise
neville longbottom der olle vollidiot
der kommt halt so häufig vor also den
habe ich ein paar mal gesehen aber so
einer wie tom riddle also voldemort ist
halt ziemlich selten und wenn man den
feed passiert nicht häufig weil pokémon
gz beispielsweise arenen die man
einnehmen kann und gegen diese leute die
man dann kämpfen kann uns weiter und so
fort bei nach dem spiel harry potter
resolution gibt es beispielsweise dann
allerdings so was wie gasthäuser oder
gewächshäuser wo man tränke brauen kann
oder festungen wo man dann tatsächlich
auch richtig kämpfen kann das spiel ist
also extrem umfangreich also es gibt
mega viel zu entdecken und wenn man
harry potter fan ist dass das spiel auf
jeden fall muss allerdings habe ich noch
gar nicht so viel gezockt hat mich viel
mehr darüber informiert weil zocken tun
wir den ganzen apparat jetzt zusammen
weil so los geht's mit dem gameplay zu
allererst müssen uns dem ministry
erstellen
das ist unser ministeriums
außenministeriums auswärts geht einfach
nur darum dass wir halt sagen was unser
hogwarts haus ist wir müssen den foto
auswählen und so weiter und so fort wir
sind natürlich welches haus sind
griffin dort jetzt müssen wir auch noch
ein foto auswählen für unseren ausweis
wahnsinn jetzt haben wir hier 1 8 das
ist jetzt unser bis jetzt unser
ministeriums ausweis passbild allerdings
soll ich nicht das ganze video von
unserem ministeriums ausweis handeln von
daher würde ich sagen ich stehe jetzt
mal auflaufen bisschen rum weil es geht
ja nicht nur darum dass man sitzen
bleibt sondern man muss ja richtig
bewegen bei dem spiel ich habe
eingesammelt gerade
die rechts neben uns sehe ich jetzt
schon ist eine wertvolle port schatulle
was seine port stadthalle gefunden diese
verschlossene muggel sicheren koffer
enthalten sogenannte porsche to make it
branche sind sogar harry potter was
genau da war da aber ich hab's ja
eingesammelt deswegen ist da nicht mehr
kein problem voll krass das tue ich auch
hier steht und da
ich bin ein bisschen frecher als harry
eigentlich in der tat also wir stehen
jetzt hier gerade bei einem haus da
könnt ihr einfach mal drauf klicken und
ihr seht schon um ihren beitrag zur
bekämpfung des desasters zu leisten
haben sich weltweit gastierte bereit
erklärt hexen und zauberer mit
kostenlosem es wichtig keine luft mehr
in seinem privatjet hallo sind jetzt auf
jeden fall hier in diesem gebäude ich
muss jetzt was nachzeichnen was sie
schon jetzt blieben hier so teile herum
und wir haben da eine teekanne asmus
fünf minuten da kann ich ja sauber
energie einsammeln und dann haben die
einfachste ich meine
warum denn nicht die andere wir können
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter
herumlaufen weil da vorne um die ecke
sehe ich auch schon ist ort bestehen
wir haben wir haben um ein gott straße
leute ich werde jetzt mal nur diese
kamera hier gerade das heißt ich schaue
mich jetzt mal hier ein bisschen und wir
müssen jetzt irgendwas suchen was hier
wohl irgendwo sein soll
oh mein gott also hier ist jetzt eine
person wir müssen die sterne direkt dort
ausrichten jetzt müssen wir das antippen
und die gefahrenstufe sehen wir schon
ist nie gerichtet heißt jetzt müssen wir
hier den zauberspruch nachzeichnen zack
und es ist brauchbar
die findung und wir haben es nicht
geschafft in hogwarts gab es keine autos
ja in gestört haben ich probiere es
jetzt nochmal mit dem zeichnen hier und
ich war zu langsam
es hat geklappt
ich habe wenigstens das ich kenne den
gar nicht du hast den fund wächter
überwältigt anwendbarer gegenstand raven
klar war dass polizei und ich würde
allerdings sagen das wäre doch mal ein
bisschen weiter hier rumlaufen ich
bekomme die ganze zeit zusammen dass ich
befördert wurde und so weiter und so
fort also spiel ist ein mega mega
umfangreiche etwas gegen die weiter
gelaufen
also ich muss jetzt hier ein bisschen
rum gucken und wir haben hier eine
person gefahrenstufe mitte also der ist
auf jeden fall ein bisschen krasser
unterwegs und jetzt das ganze noch
brauchbar
vielleicht mag es vielleicht doch nicht
der zauberspruch mit ausgesendet und der
fund wächter hat dir wieder okay
verdammt ich hab's nicht hingerichtet
die konnte widerstehen ist dein ernst
ich mache das richtig gut wieder nur
brauchbar aber vielleicht erstmal die
konnte widerstehen wichtig denn so
beschissen nicht wer was sagt wohl
schlecht in diesem spiel
[Musik]
makiko ich gehe mal kurz meinen freunden
ich kriege ich hin der graf noch ein
allerletztes mal
der war gut
in lublin sack was kommt
bei fast jungs gesagt was gesagt also
wir sind wieder dran aufgestiegen
ich würde sagen wir laufen jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen rum ich habe sumpf
schaaf gab samen oder irgendwie sowas
hab ich gerade auch eingesammelt ich
würde allerdings sagen weil er liebe
freude bevor ich das vergessen zu
erwähnen es gibt gerade auch eine mega
cool denn aktion bei harry potter
rezession als gewesen
[Musik]
meine frau wollte da nicht das ingame
event geht auf jeden fall vom 17 12
bis zum 24 12 10 ball und alle harry
potter fans wissen was der ball war das
war glaube ich nach dem traumatischen
turnier der abschlussball wo hermine mit
diesem bulgaren war doch eh keiner dabei
geht es auf jeden fall darum dass man
die erinnerungen von heute und seinen
freunden einfangen zweite das video
allerdings gerade später schauen solltet
also nach dem 24 dezember ist hat jetzt
wo ich jetzt hier für verkehr es gibt
auf jeden fall noch ein zweites cooles
ingame event das geht vom 20 12
bis zum 6 januar und zwar ist es dass
genau das trifft haas of christmas event
und dabei geht es darum zu machen haben
nicht ganz man muss zwölf weihnachts
aufgaben erledigen und kann dann
geschenke beispielsweise auch mit
freunden teilen wenn man beispielsweise
in irgendwelchen festungen schatz grund
findet dann das kind auch
man kann auf jeden fall geschenkboxen
finden und wenn man dann beispielsweise
runensteine kriegt dann kann man die mit
freunden teilen und sich austauschen und
et cetera befährt für zeigen
[Musik]
ich bin auf jeden fall wieder zu hause
ankommen wie ihr unschwer erkennt man
doch wohl mein zuhause hat mich diese
müllhalde gedanke auf jeden fall nochmal
wie gerade schon gesagt an glück im
rahmen der kampagne für das mega mega
tolle gewinnspiele
auch noch mal herzlichen glückwunsch an
die drei leute die ihre mindestwerte
gepostet haben und somit auch gewonnen
haben auf instagram und jetzt dieses
paket hier bekommen also ich war alles
megacool das ganze jetzt immer noch teil
der google erklärung kampagne nicht
jetzt schon tausend mal gesagt habe wo
ich ja früher etwas zerstört ein paar
wochen dieser mobile man jetzt mit luca
serie hatte und dann gesagt super
gefallen macht ein videoportal deswegen
wenn es euch gefallen das gerne daumen
hoch da das spiel ist in der video
beschreibung verlinkt also harry potters
united oft und gern mal vorbei führt wie
bereits schon gesagt megacool ingame
events gerade laufen sind also checkt es
auf jeden fall haus aber nicht meinen
kanal neuen hat die letzten vier wörter
ich liebe mich so
[Musik]